attempt to jump off a cliff on a
motorcycle then parachute off the
motorcycle
Mission Impossible yeah what if they put
everything in place like they did for
Old Tommy Boy I don't know if I can I
mean Tom puts the hours in you know he
does the training months and months of
training yeah I got to play Minecraft
with my kid you know I gotta walk my dog
I got stuff I need to do
could you impersonate one of your
castmates wearing one of those high-tech
spy masks yeah I think you could
possible you're a professional on that
front yeah I could do a pretty good Tom
I think I'd get out there with a Tom
mask cause Havoc let him pick up the
Times Square is right outside
all right um climb a mountain with no
rope like Tom and Mission Impossible Too
okay I feel you on that I'm right there
with you ever since I've had kids I'm
like I just I'm very risk-averse you
know everything everything just becomes
a bear no I need to I need to do dad
stuff I hear you I can't risk that